former Atlanta police officer Garrett
Roth will face a judge for the first
time today in connection with the death
of Rashard Brooks this is Ralph's mug
shot after he turned himself in to
police yesterday he is now being held
without bond on felony murder and 10
other charges
now Ralph's attorney says he's confident
that once all the evidence comes out his
client will be vindicated
mark Strassmann is in Atlanta with more
on that story so Marc what's the next
step here good morning Gail right after
former officer Ralph was booked for
felony murder he was transferred to a
different County Jail the death penalty
is now off the table in his case and his
arrest has sent waves of resentment
through the police agency he used to
work for CBS News cameras captured
former officer Garrett Rolfe arriving at
the Fulton County Jail that's him
wearing the baseball cap 48 minutes
later he was booked for felony murder
hours earlier the other charged officer
Devon Brosnan posted bond and left the
jail he faces charges of aggravated
assault and violation of oath Brosnan's
attorney john samuel you know you're
gonna charge a police officer who's
giving CPR and putting anticoagulant in
the in the wounds and compression
bandages you said we didn't do it fast
enough we're gonna charge you with a
felony for that come on
but District Attorney Paul Howard is
adamant he did not overcharge either
officer he says after the shooting ruff
kicked Brooks and Brosnan stood on his
shoulder after mr. Brooks was shot for
some period of 2 minutes and 12 seconds
there was no medical attention applied
to mr. Brooks officer Brosnan spoke out
for the first time since the shooting he
recalled his initial interaction with
Brooks I felt he was friendly he was
respectful respectful to see what I
could do if I made sure that he was safe
as for what comes next with any
investigators or interesting
conversation about what happened that
night
Roy fired three shots
to hit Brooks in the back one bullet
strayed and hit a car waiting and the
Wendy's drive-through Michael Perkins
was riding in that car in response to
the Chargers some Atlanta officers are
reportedly calling in sick the city says
the department is still able to respond
to all calls police departments are
feeling very cherished at this time
Atlanta's interim police chief Rodney
Bryant says the no-shows are not
coordinated but some officers are
unhappy with the charges some angry some
more fearful some are confused on what
we do in this space a shaken department
and a shattered family the family of
raesha Brooks his funeral will be next
Tuesday Anthony
mark Strassmann thank you Mark